to be able to sort of put up the Asian  male as a attractive leading man I think  it means a lot that's something that  even my brother who's the oldest brother  and he's six - is the athlete he has  banners all over the high school I was  like the nerdy guy but he's like the  cool all my friends are friend with me  to be friends with him  he watched the movie I showed him and he  when Henry went when our Nick Young  comes out of the house in his white suit  and he's just like perfect a movie star  purvey my brother started to cry he's  not a crier and I said what wasn't what  are you doing he's like you have no idea  what this means to see ourselves up  there and feel proud of of being an  Asian man instead of being embarrassed  of being that that means the world to me